[Música]
porque analizamos la situación en el
terreno de guerra luego a cumplirse
cuatro meses desde que inició la
invasión rusa ucrania y que las tropas
ucranianas se retiraran de la ciudad de
severodonezk esta estrategia esta
estratégica urbe era la última de gran
importancia en la región que aún no
estaba parcialmente bajo el control
ucraniano con esta retirada las fuerzas
rusas se ganan aún más terreno para
controlar completamente la zona del
donbass esta situación le permitirá
entonces a rusia establecer un corredor
con las regiones del sur que ya controla
y que en particular con la península de
crimea que ocupa desde el año 2014 vamos
entonces a saludar a nuestro primer
invitado del día él es oleksandr es el
choque analista del instituto ucraniano
para las relaciones internacionales
oleksandr gracias por su tiempo por
estar con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24 le pregunto entonces el cuál
es la situación actual en el terreno de
la guerra en ucrania y por supuesto la
importancia de esta región del donbass
que casi ya controla completamente rusia
buenas tardes brindarme poniendo más es
correcto que la profesora ucranianas ya
han retirado de la ciudad de segundones
a la ciudad vecina a la ciudad satélites
de xichang pues nuevas tropas rusas
ahora casi controlan la región de la
franja que se ocuparon pero la región de
donets está ocupado sólo la mitad
50% por eso la condición es el objetivo
de ucrania restricciones a las
posiciones más protegidas para salvar la
vida humana porque alguien necesitamos
los soldados vivos para la entrega
masiva de armamentos por eso hay que
salvar la vida de la gente en tumbas o
sea ejecutar una estrategia de bombardeo
masivo y de destrucción total la tierra
quemada y por eso no hay ninguna
necesidad a controlar esa tierra de la
tropas ucranianas se ejecutan una
estratégica una táctica mejor automática
no hay que controlar el territorio hay
que salvar la vida humana y los equipos
los armamentos y por eso se refieren a
las condiciones más protegidas hasta
cuando podrían resistir las tropas
ucranianas también tienen en cuenta el
envío de armamento de occidente sin
dejar a un lado que rusia por supuesto
tiene como objetivo estos depósitos de
armas de armas en ucrania para poder
destruirlas y que no se puedan defender
los militares ucranianos las cosas que
finalmente ocaña recibió dos sistemas de
cohetes sistemas de cohetes y más
estados estadounidenses y con esos
sistemas ya hemos bombardeado los
almacenes de municiones rusos en la
retaguardia profunda de rusia más allá
en el sector de tumbas y con esa
estrategia vamos a seguir porque nuestro
objetivo es el cesar en frenar el avance
al uso y para que no se pierda de las
mediciones para su posible ofensiva y
claro que los los armamentos sólo van a
dejar a ucrania por cierto ese es un
proceso y la actuación de tiempo y por
eso yo creo que la guerra de dos vasos
de vida sigue y si las tropas sus
finanzas se describen eso no significa
que no van a empezar la contraofensiva
después porque ucrania estaba buscando
una guerra de calidad rusia mucho de
quieren de cantidad y por eso o nuestra
única posibilidad de empezar la
contraofensiva eres
los planteles de momentos pesados que
por cierto va a ocurrir durante el
verano y finalmente el famoso de la
lista americano aquí funciona ucrania
recibe los argumentos occidentales y eso
nos ayuda a empezar la ofensiva local en
el sur porque sabemos que en el sur o
tocón sufre más es paso a paso
pero toman el control son pro pueblos en
los territorios del sur de obrar claro
alexander y también recordemos que ya a
partir de mañana se inicia formalmente
esta cumbre de la otan recordemos
organismos y países que han apoyado
activamente digamos en armamento a
ucrania que se pudiera esperar de esta
reunión esta nueva reunión de la otan en
cuanto a seguir apoyando a ucrania
armamentística mente
pero yo estoy seguro que van a seguir
con eso porque en la otan en el
occidente unido general ya entienden que
debemos hacer bruselas sentarse a la
mesa desde cualquier sones y en los
parlamentos eso es imposible rusia no
quieren negociar la paz y tranquilidad y
estabilidad en europa por eso lo
entregue de momento es esta única
posibilidad para hacer de moscú a
negociar la retirada de sus tropas
ahora se habla sobre
finalmente se llama con la entrega de
argumentos alemanes y también de países
bajos pues en europa ya existe un
compromiso que hay que continuar con la
anterior del momento salgan por cierto y
yo creo que la decisión de la otan va a
ser la misma que él va a demostrar su
unidad porque el cultivo de putin el
objetivo de reducción de esa guerra fue
destruir esa unidad del occidente ahora
estados unidos y europa demuestran que
están listos para enfrentar la amenaza
rusa porque lo que hace es que es un
claro hablaba alexander de una
negociación entre las partes no entre
ucrania para poder así llegar al fin de
esta guerra también comienzo nada algo
muy importante y es de este armamento
precisamente que la entrega occidente a
ucrania que es clave para que se sienten
al diálogo porque
por qué
la mayoría de los expertos y yo también
el equipo de acción personal que rusia
no está lista en inglaterra para
cualquier uso teoría no tiene pérdidas
suficientes suficientes en el campo de
batalla a rusia excede 0 desde la
provincia de que ir en marzo y en en
abril porque hirió las pérdidas sufrió
los peces y lo mismo debe ocurrir en los
vasos en el sur sólo después sólo con
una herramienta de innovación sólo
después el régimen de putin un régimen
autoritario va a sentarse a la mesa de
negociaciones porque ucrania mucho
contra un régimen totalitario o con o no
contra una democracia por eso ellos
entienden sólo violación y nada más
alexander ya para finalizar nuestra
conversaciones le quiero preguntar sobre
este territorio que ahora controla rusia
cree que en algún momento o en este
diálogo se pueda negociar ser devuelto a
ucrania qué va a pasar con este
territorio ocupado
en este territorio ocupado la población
en su mayoría apoya
claro que apoya a las autoridades
ucranianas y por eso es una cosa muy
importante porque no existe ninguna
lealtad local de la gente que viva ahí a
la administración de ocupación de rusa
ellos son los rusos los ocupantes y por
eso es la cuestión de tiempo cuando van
a regresar el control no se no se habla
sobre ninguna perdió de territorio
porque es la gente en aquellos editores
en bombas en el sur todavía ha seguido
con lealtad prou ucraniana eso es muy
importante para sí